[Musique]
titov
je joue bien et c'était le concert par
jim boumelha plastique
[Musique]
j'avais déjà fait mon choix je ne sors
pas de bol c'est à deux balles allez
l'apprend touchant ce n'est pas cet
abruti par là mais tout chaud pourquoi
tu me dises de suite une couille un
couloir
si loin
ce qui est génial je faisais mes achats
de vin si vous posez vous pouvez vous
essayer de dents
dans votre pratique un dieu qu'est ce
que t'es pas
avec dix maillots splashy j'espère
partir tout pas très
mais je mets vrai là
[Musique]
[ __ ] le siège en pétard opt
servez pas moi
ce cri que ça ne coûte pas merdé que
nous sommes en train de faire
merde à damier